Salut, aujourd'hui plus qu'un vlog, je vous fais decouvrir mon setup...
...et les coulisses de la création de mes vidéos.
Vous me l'avez demandé plusieurs fois dans les commentaires,
vous l'avez aussi demandé lors des FAQ :
Alors aujourd'hui je prends un moment sous le soleil ardent de ce 20 juin... C'est formidable...
Pour vous faire voir mon setup !
Je n'étais pas persuadé que ça vous intéresserais, apparament si.
En source de lumiére principale, je suis censé me servir du soleil.
Je dis bien censé, parce que c'est pas toujours le cas. Du coup j'ai 2 petites "soft box"
qui me permettent de m'éclairer.
**démonstration**
Pour le son j'utilise rien de particulier, simplement le son de la caméra.
parce que la prise de son se fait en stéréo, par contre c'est un omnidirectionnelle donc suivant où je filme... c'est un peu galére.
Je vais peut-être penser plus tard a m'équiper d'un micro.
Pour les caméras j'en utilise 2 principalement. Si j'ai besoin d'un point de vue personnel, c'est a dire de vous mettre a ma place,
je vais utiliser la gopro
la "hero 3" que vous connaissez surement.
je me mets ça sur le torse et la gopro dedans, comme ça vous pouvez voir à travers mes yeux.
La caméra que j'utilise au quotidien c'est la "Canon legria mini x" **Lien dans le descriptif**
qui me permet de m'auto-cadrer, elle est un peu limitée au niveau des réglages de l'ouverture, de la balance des blanc, mais elle a un tres bon son . On peux l'emmener partout.
Elle est légere, elle a une bonne autonomie, je l'avais avant de commencer les vidéos sur YouTube donc forcement ça m'évitait de reinvestir.
Et puis pour le moment elle convient tres bien pour le défi de cette année.
Au niveau de la méthodologie pour écrire, tourner, monter,
vous publier les vidéos.
Déjà sachez que je suis en flux tendu, ça veux dire que, en général, j'écrie, je tourne, je monte la vidéo le jour même pour vous la mettre a 17h.
J'ai pas un stock d'avance, alors forcement c'est un peu galère parce que tout les jours il faut être réactif.
Par contre l'avantage, je peux être réactif avec vous ! Je peux vous poser des questions sur les réseaux sociaux, je peux me fier à vos commentaires.
Et ça c'est vraiment le côté agreable des vidéos, juste une exception dans la chaine : en général la vidés du dimanche j'essaie de la tourner le samedi soir, comme ça le dimanche matin je peux dormir un peu...
Au niveau des sujets c'est souvent au jour le jour, j'essaie d'ecrire des sujets d'avance. je me fie également beaucoup à vos commentaires...
...que je note ici, quand vous me parlez d'un sujet que vous aimeriez avoir, comme cette vidéo du setup,
je le note dans le carnet à idée.
et comme ça le matin je feuillète et je choisi un sujet.
par exemple bientôt je vais faire une vidéo sur la lecture rapide parce que vous me l'avez demandé.
ensuite je prends une feuille de bristol, je ne sais pourquoi j'aime travailler dessus, j'adore écrire sur les feuilles comme ça.
- sur ce genre de fiche -
je détaille toute l'idée, j'essaie de créer un schéma cohérent, ensuite je mets tout ce que je sais.
Je fais des recherches si je veux compléter où si je veux être sûr de moi.
et je structure une espèce de shéma avec des idées clés, mots clés, des choses que je ne veux pas oublier.
je tourne la vidéo ca me prends entre 20 et 30 minutes.
Comme vous avez pu le voir sur d'autres vidéos je travaille sur un mac bookpro.
Un MacBook pro octobre 2011.
Et je monte sur final cut pro.
le 10.
Le montage me prends entre 1h-1h30 plus l'export 2h. Pendant que ça se transfert sur YouTube,
avec pixelmator, je créé la vignette. C'est la où je passe le moins de temps malheureusement parce qu'il faudrait des super vignettes .
Mais à un moment donné je ne peux pas tout faire, j'ai pas forcément la compétence ni le temps de tout faire.
Puis une fois que la vidéo est bien placer sur YouTube je mets la vignette et là il faut créer le titre : et pour le créer il faut le trouver ! Ensuite la description, les mots-clé,
je la mets dans les playlists, je programme l'heure de sortie à 17h et là ce n'est pas finit !
Il faut que je créé toutes les fiches et les annotations, les liens entre les vidéos, l'annotation qui fait que quand vous cliquez sur le logo en haut à gauche vous pouvez vous abonner et ça fais un lien direct.
ça prends du temps, c'est pas ce qui prends le plus de temps mais c'est juste le côté decourageant.
Une fois que t'as tout fait, t'as encore ça à faire derriére.
et après c'est terminé... sauf si je veux la partager sur les réseaux sociaux . Dans ce cas là j'ai encore une étape en plus.
pour créer un mini clip vidéo que je vous mets sur les réseaux sociaux, je le fais pas trop d'ailleurs en ce moment.
Voila vous connaissez maintenant toute la mécanique de la création de mes vidéos. Tout ce que j'utilise comme matériel.
C'est pas un gros setup, c'est pas un énorme setup, mais comme vous vouliez le voir vous avez eu tous les détails, même les logiciels que j'utilise.
J'espère que cette courte vidéo vous a plus.
N'oubliez pas de la gratifier d'un léger POUCE EN L'AIR !
N'oubliez pas de cliquer sur le logo ou sur l'outro après parce que je fais les annotations exprès pour que vous puissiez vous abonner d'un simple clic :D
Puisque le mentalvlog c'est 1 vidéo par jour pendant 1 an ! Rendez-vous demain a 17h : Tchao !!!
***outro***